Одеського екс-губернатора Міхаіла Саакашвілі
підозрюють у сприянні злочинному угруповуванню.
Такі підозри озвучили СБУ та Генпрокуратура.
Вранці 5 грудня він намагався втекти дахами
від спецпризначенців СБУ, що нагрянули
до нього додому з обшуком.
За словами генпрокурора Юрія Луценка, Саакашвілі
планував захоплення влади в Україні з метою
припинити переслідування людей
президента-втікача Януковича.
Луценко стверджує, що Саакашвілі отримав
півмільйона доларів від ще одного втікача - олігарха
Сергія Курченка на свою політичну діяльність в Україні.
У представництві німецького фонду Фрідріха Еберта
у Києві, мяко кажучи, здивовані новим витком
скандалу навколо Саакашвілі.
Особливо враховуючи те, що буквально днями
міграційна служба подовжила екс-президенту Грузії
термін перебування в Україні.
Для України це щось нове.
Після Євромайдана ніхто не очікував, що влада буде
використовувати правоохоронні інструменти проти
«нелюбих» політичних конкурентів.
Але ж Саакашвілі не становить великої небезпеки для Порошенка.
Швидше за все йшлося лише про те, щоб перед
виборами вияснити, хто може бути реальним
кандидатом, у кого шанси потрапити у Верховну Раду.
Екс-президента Грузії так і не відвезли у СБУ на допит.
Його прибічники завадили цьому, заблокувавши
автівку та повибивавши у ній вікна.
Після цього політик навіть пройшовся центром
Києва закликаючи: «Київ, вставай!»
Саакашвілі отримав, що хотів.
Адже те, що робить влада, привертає до нього
ще більше уваги.
Останній протест, який організував Саакашвілі
проти Порошенка, зібрав максимум
дві з половиною - три тисячі учасників, переважно пенсіонерів.
Судячи з усього, після подій із затриманням
Саакашвілі отримав набагато більше прибічників,
які приєдналися до його мітингу і до закликів
щодо імпічменту президента.
На думку деяких оглядачів, через дедалі зростаюче
соціальне невдоволення серед українців "ефект
Саакашвілі" може стати відправною точкою для
масових протестних акцій в Україні.